رحله من ورا رحله عمرها 10 سنين اخذت
حياتي كلياته خلونا نطير مع بعض سوا حتى
نتعرف عليها
اول فيديو
كلنا نحنا وصغار كانوا يسالونا سؤال
بالمدرسه لما كنا صغار كانوا يقولوا لنا
شو بدكم تصيروا بالمستقبل او شو الشيء
اللي ممكن تنجحوا فيه ونحن كنا نسال حالنا
نفس السؤال بس كان جوابنا على قده يمكن
لانه بهداك العمر كنا صغار او ما كان عنا
تفكير زياده لانه كنا بهذاك العمر صغير
بيوم من الايام كنت لاقي الاطفال يلي
حواليه وبعمري
مدائن مكانه بهوايات مختلفه ملائيين حالهم
بنجاحات مختلفه مثل رسم سباحه كره سله كره
قدم بس انا ما كنت لاقي حالي بهذا المكان
ليوم من الايام كنت فاضح عم بتفرج على
افلام كرتون كنت راضي
بهذاك الوقت طلع على ام بي سي 3 ضيقه وحده
ضيقه واحده كان طالع فيها شخص خلال الفاصل
الاعلاني بين الافلام كرتون
مربعه هيك بلش يطوي فحسيت في شي جسدني
لهالموضوع
لما بلش يطوي
جبت ورقه بيضاء مربعه مثله اول طويله
بطويها
بوقتها حسيت هالشي جازبني وكملت لحد ما
اكتشفت انه هالشي اسمه فن الاوريجامي فن
طي الورق فنياباني اشتهر بالقرن السادس
الميلادي هو عباره عن كلمتين اوري معناتها
كنا نحنا بنعرف
هو عباره عن فراشه عباره عن
قارب سفينه طياره او حتى مثل لما كنا نحنا
وصغار نكمل طيارات ونرميهم على الاستاذ
المدرسه او
او مثلا نجي نلعب نحن ورفقاتنا في القوارب
ونغرقهم بالمي بس نحن يا ترى كنا بنعرف
انه فن طي الورق هو فن الو تقنيتين تقنيه
التودي وتقنيه الثري دي تقنيه هي عباره عن
ورقه واحده ورقه نقدر نعمل فيها اي شكل
بدنا اياه بس ما بيخلينا نطلع في شكل
ثلاثي الابعاد وطنيه 3d هي عباره عن
اشكال تعطينا ثلاثيه الابعاد مثل هذول
الاشكال اللي عنا لحتى نقدر حتى كمان نصمم
بورتريهات ونصمم لوجو لحتى مثل كانه رستم
رسوم عم يشرح وش اي شخص ويرسموا قدامه نحن
نفس الحكي بس عباره عن شو عباره عن مضاد
يلي انا تعلمته من الكتب تبع الاوريغامي
الكتب موجود فيها اساسيات لحتى نقدر نتعلم
فنطي الورق وكمان موجود فيها كيف ممكن نحن
نشرح يعني شخصيه الانسان ونعمله بالورق
وكمان فينا نعمل شخصيات كرتونيه هي نفسها
اللي انا هلا بوقتها منها واقف قدامكم
فينا نعملهم لحد يعني شي ملموس قدامنا بس
يا ترى نعرف انه فن طي الورق هو بخص
هندسه معماريه بيخص يعني حلم الطفوله
بالنسبه لالي
فن طي الورق بقلب اذا فينا ندمج مع
العماره هو عباره عن فولدينج بيسموها
تقنيه العماره المصريه او العماره المطويه
خلينا نقول هي عباره عن دمج الاوريغامي مع
العمارب بس يا ترى شو ممكن يطلع منه يطلع
منه هيك تصاميم هاد جناح اليابان باكسبو
دبي 2020
ضمن المهندس اللي صممه واخذ المرتبه
الثانيه اكثر تميزا من بين الجناحات يعني
التصميمون احسن او احلى وتصرح المهندس تبع
المصمم قال انه نحن دمج عنا باليابان اللي
هو الاوريجامي مع فن طي مع الهندسه
المعماريه يعني دليل على ذلك انه نحن فينا
ندمج المهاره الفنيه مع المهاره
الاكاديميه بس يا ترى كمان وين راح توصلنا
وين انا حتوصلني هالقصه انا ما كنت لاقي
مكاني وانا صغير مثل الاطفال الباقيين
مكانهم يلاقوا مكانهم
رسم انا ما كنت لاقي مكاني هون انا هلا
لقيت مكاني بالاوريغامي وانا هلا قدامكم
بصفتي غيث الساعدي الفنان الاول بسوريا
وصاحب المعرض الاول بسوريا
الاوريغامي علمني كتير شغلات ترك فيني
اثار بحياتي هي غيرت الشخص اللي واقف
قدامكم هي خلت غيث هذا اللي واقف قدامكم
غير رئيس الصغير اللي كان كل همه اللعب
وكان همه يعني خلينا نقول بالعاميه
الاردني مثل
اليوم انا واقف قدامكم بعد عشر سنين من
شغلي بالاوريغامي بلشت صف رابع لحد الان
انا قاعد عم بشتغل بالاوريغامي ولحد الان
ما وقفت طموحي انا سميته بالنسبه لالي هي
رحله السعاده لانه انا هاي الرحله هي غيرت
من حياتي كتير شغلات تعلمتني الصبر علمتني
الخيال وعلمتني الاراده يمكن انا لو بهذاك
الوقت اختصرت وانا بصفي رابع هتضيق لو
شفتوني هلا هون كنتوا شفتوني هلا غيث يلي
بضل بس بيسمع كلام اهله انه عمل هيك وعمل
هيك ما لحقت طموحه بس انا تعلمت قوه
الاراده انه انت اذا عندك شيء بالعكس خليك
وراه لانه انت راح تكون الداعم الوحيد
لنفسك وانت الداعم
الابدي لحالك قبل اي شخص ما يجي يدعمك لما
انت تكون رضيان عن حالك هاي اهم شغله هون
بتبلش خطوه نجاحك لما انت يكون من جواتك
في اكتفاء ذاتي
وكمان علمني الصبر ولهلا عم يعلمني اياه
بسبب تبعات الكهرباء
ههه
انا اليوم وجه رسالتين رساله لكل حدا بعمر
غيث انت مالك عاجز عندك ياس انه ما تكمل
بطريق يمكن انت حلمك تصير لاعب كره قدم
مثل كريستيانو ميسي وممكن انت حابب تكون
مشهور كره السله او اي شيء يعني بسيط
بالحياه مثل ما انا صرت بسبب هالورقه بسبب
ورقه بسيطه يلي هي ابسط شيء بالوجود فانتم
كملوا انتوا ضلو احلموا لانه الاراده
احلامنا لما بتعطش بالاراده بترتوي نحن
الاراده من عندنا المنبع فنحن اذا ما كنا
نمبر نفسنا وما راح نكون ما راح نكون لحدا
غيرنا حتى ورسالتي لكل حدا من الاهالي انه
تابعوا شغف اولادكم تابعوا شغف ابنكم
ابنكم يمكن يلاقوا حالهم بابسط شيء يمكنوا
حالهم في شي انتوا اللي بتحبوه بالعكس
اعطونا مساحتهم يعبروا عن الشيء اللي هم
بدهم يعبروا عن الشيء يلي هنن بيحبوه
والشيء اللي هن حابين يطمحوا له وينجحوا
فيه لانه اذا صاروا مثل النجوم انتم وقت
حتفتخروا فيهم انه خليتوهم يلحقوا طموحهم
ما لحقت ما خليتون يتدمر بسبب احلامكم
انتم وهلا اليوم انا لقيت شغفي وكنت معكم
[تصفيق]